you do not win any awards for being a
good daughter there are many stories
where I don't wear I was not a great
daughter I I am forever in my mum's debt
because I was such a brat and I feel
really bad about it tell us a story
about when you're on your computer and
she wanted your help oh yes she yes okay
so I um I was on MSN uh obviously the
most important thing at the time
and uh we lived out like you know out in
the sticks and often snakes would get
into the house and
um you know it wasn't a big deal but you
just have to like chase them around and
get it out and it's kind of time
consuming and annoying and so my mom
yelled out and she was like can you come
help me this this snake's really big
like I can't get it on my own can you
come help me and I was like
so busy mum no I can't like just being a
brat because I was on a mission and she
was like oh I just like hey are you
pleased and I was like big on and um and
then she was she was gone for like 10
minutes and I was like
oh she's been gone for ages and then I I
like got up from the computer I could
hear like this
and I was like oh God what's happening
and I see mum she's like made it halfway
down the stairs and the snake she tried
to like pick this big python up with her
but with a broom and a stick but it had
wound its way up around her arm and was
going around her neck
Australia but I would never be able to
no I know I'm painting a bad picture
it's really not bad but um and it wasn't
poisonous
it's a poisonous state that they do they
do they do strangle you oh yeah
so bad and not an offer you just got to
give it something else to climb on so
you get a stick or something it starts
weaving its way around that and then you
can transfer its weight and good to know
get it off yeah
just you grab it behind its head you
grab it behind us
you just don't want it to bite you
with him comes the ultimate Accolade a
wax work now Kylie you've been in Madame
tutors how many times there's been loads
of versions five maybe five different
ones but they've I think they've just
changed it again well I think this is
this the last one this isn't the new one
this is the last one I think
that was second to last
and then they had to actually replace
bits of it because so many members of
the public were doing this
oh
three three bombs the wax wore down
doing are you standing now I'm sat down
so if I'm actually on my bottom very
good is it true Russell you don't like
Wax work I hate them they're creepy
absolutely they give me the
and anytime that anybody puts one up we
we hassle them for years we chase them
down and we make them melted
milk that lumpy thing so this one won't
last for long then it's already gone
that that's 10 years ago we pursued
those people and it's gone chopped off
his head is it just a tiger and look how
that is yeah it is
absolutely ridiculous
[Applause]
I just think it's such a weird thing I
have just no desire and like you know
Madam just I'll send you a letter and I
just get no no thanks not just not
interested you know actually funny
enough we were ringing round uh wax
museums in Australia to see if there was
one of you there to show a picture of it
and uh one of them said no no we don't
have a wax work of Russell Crowe but we
have a letter from Russell do you know
this letter so they wrote to you to say
I was just not one of the abusive ones
no no no
this is such a sweet letter here's the
here's the letter so it says uh dear
pleasure uh sorry mate no interest at
all in being made out of wax please do
not pursue this any further you don't
divide Mission normal blessing apart
from that I hope you and your family are
doing well
[Applause]
this is so bad I mean it's really
amazing
oh my God
looks like a wolverine origin movie that
you had to do the running naked down the
corridor uh now there was X-Men two yeah
no I've actually no first day of X-Men
Origins I ran naked I seem to I quite
enjoy it really
it's a very freeing feeling
so I want to take your clothes off it's
wonderful should we do it no
so
I remember we had to go down this
hallway and I had to run I was meant to
be naked and and it was very dark and
and I I jokingly went in I said I want a
closed set for this and the first idea
was laughing anyway went to the first
take and I'm running as a very intense
scene where I first realized I have an
adamantium skeleton I've been
experimenting I'm naked there's blood
I'm like ah and as I run around the
corner the first ID had the entire crew
of FEMA it's all the females on the crew
with like five dollar knives going
and of course the first thing I did was
like oh
I did cut myself
when you see the inner thigh do you mean
I'm actually being a guy thankfully wow
yes DIY circumcision
I did the guy Elvis hits PG-13 so you
can't have bits and pieces flying about
right yeah the senses in America don't
like that kind of stuff
and in on as my rap gear from uh from
Brian Singer the director he gave me a
bag and it was a little bag and it was
very light I looked inside it had film
inside it and I'm like what's film and I
look up okay
my bits in bits you've made the choice
to bring your children back to Australia
yeah yeah so were they all born in
America and then you brought them back
uh no my daughter was born here in
London actually yep and then the boys
were born in America and we moved back
to Australia and uh
liver now you've posted pictures online
and it makes me think was bringing your
children back there that wise like you
pit was this but like that's your house
yeah that is uh that's yeah one of the
bedrooms yeah is it one of the
children's bedrooms
occasionally yeah yeah and not since
that snake lives there and then you pick
because this one as well like is that in
your house it is yeah yeah they're
better than Paparazzi though those
animals okay
I would take Paparazzi Over The Spider
and the snake yeah you know that snake
the what you don't see we'd had a couple
of drinks that night when we discovered
that snake in the bedroom and uh I I
love Australia I love Australia we've
had a few drinks before we found the
snake
it was a Friday or Saturday night and um
and we're standing going what is it and
someone's like it's a brown snake which
can kill you you know very quickly
someone's like no it's a tree python
it's something else it's this and I just
launched into like action mode grabbed
it by the tail picked it up up and
everyone starts freaking out and it
starts to kind of coil itself back up
toward me which is getting ready to
strike and I remember thinking what the
hell am I doing so I just kind of threw
the snake back into the bedroom
shut the door
and we don't go in that bedroom anymore
I boarded that thing up we have a little
mobile with stars and Suns on it
could I just say I think I've done very
well I've held off to this point in the
show before mentioning uh guys seminal
work as Mike young in Neighbors
okay
I was about to walk off the set I know
if you were thinking when when will he
mention my work now obviously uh this is
never far from my uh my neighbors who's
who wow where's Jenny when you're
excited about this aren't you I bet
there's some good haircuts in there oh
you get the whole back page
check that out yeah yeah but that's the
who's who I think I know where the
neighbors can I have that of course you
can hey that is yours that is yours
because Olivia Europe you were a big
neighbor's fan weren't you yes well
still are I'm sure
oh yeah
I was then in the uh yeah sort of night
early 90s
but we know what's the time neighbors
have sort of come back into your life it
never goes away Graham
well it has sort of come back into my
life because there was a little we had a
little sort of Twitter exchange recently
because Annie Jones who plays Jane has
gone back on the show Plain Jane Super
Brain Plain Jane stupid brain my the
love of my life of course and uh there
was a storyline where it that was
implied that she was going to sort of go
off with uh uh Stefan who plays uh
Robinson and I just sent this tweet out
going Jane No
and then Steph made this video saying
well you know nice tweet guy you know uh
why don't you come back on the show and
why don't we have it out together you
know anyway so it was a sort of funny
banter and then we found out that
actually those guys were here in the UK
so we caught up and uh you know we we
took some photos together with Annie
sort of you know thus fighting and Annie
sort of keeping us apart oh there you
are there you are oh no plain Jane
sewerbrain very upset yeah
which gray-haired man will I go with
you don't want to make anyone cry but
there are sad days in the publishing
World in Australia I don't know if
you're aware of this but I'm afraid
Dolly magazine has shut its doors Nicole
Dolly magazine is no more daily magazine
was very important to you when you were
starting out wasn't it yeah yeah yeah I
got on the cover of Dolly magazine here
we go there you are on the cover yeah
you look you look fabulous I dyed my
hair red that's only like 14. but you
sure it wasn't red like that everyone
always thinks it was that red and it
wasn't no they dyed it red inside there
are some Fabulous High fashion shots of
you oh God
this this
is this it gives me gives you an idea of
the quality of fashion in Dolly magazine
um
jacket I I'm saying these rope scenes
I'm not sure they ever caught on the
Rope scene I've never seen it before in
my life but this next picture this is
God you're brutal so no there's only one
more I don't want more so so I wish I
honestly wish my hair was like that now
and so it's so Dreadful I because I I
have to say anyone that has curly hair
that's young keep your curly hair don't
straighten it because after a while you
don't get your curls back really no they
just they kind of become just frizz Mass
I mean that is frismus but I kind of
like that
yeah it's gone so I'm like an old woman
now where I say don't die yeah and don't
straighten your curls what I like that
idea you know when photographers in
movies when they're doing you know and
they're always like oh look sexy or give
me something give me this or you know
try this
what had the photographer said
this picture
[Applause]
is this the sort of thing you're after
photographer can I see your pants
we'll take it away we'll take it away
there you go Dolly magazine all right
we need to go back to your early life
yes because you started you were very
young were you when you saw it I was
once very young no no when you put me
sorry yeah yes I was 15 when I started
singing and then your first film
a funny thing happened down under yes
now I think there's oh funny things
happened down there
I like the way up here they have in the
corner comedy
just in case people got the wrong end of
the stick this must be the re-release
because
um I was never the star of this movie I
had a small part
no is this is this an ad this picture
actually no it was a famous photographer
was visiting my house and wanted to take
a picture of me and omo was the you know
the brand of soap powder that was
popular at the time
do they don't make omo anymore I don't
think so no no I wonder why they stopped
yeah I wasn't going to go there but
anyway
oh they're hitting this one now is this
an ad uh no I don't think so I don't
know what that one is I thought possibly
deodorant
now I am very lucky
well I have a large collection of and I
think
some people watching me not and with
these These are long playing records
look he's got some in the front row
there as well
traded your laser
it is interesting to see where your
image has changed over the years because
in the beginning you know you're all
look so kind of Virgin and gorgeous oh
there's a little bit raunchy another one
of those underarm deodorant things yeah
you were keen on that weren't you yeah
if you're very proud of yourself and
look oh so pretty
lovely then look sexing it up a bit I
think that was after Greece all right so
a blouse on jacket
and this one then nudity's implied I
feel
and then
I don't quite
even now that's a tough one to get away
with
but then ladies and gentlemen
I know this helmet Newton took that and
it's Posh isn't it
your image
I'm so sorry I've confused around
I don't know if you've ever had one of
these uh Joan your very own board game
I'll try that Jason you don't call this
uh Straight From the Heart do you
straight from my ass
[Laughter]
um interesting game it was a number one
game uh in its time yeah when was its
time uh
probably the late 80s oh yeah that was
my time too yeah
that's why we were on the show tonight
[Applause]
it was very sweet
but they're all they're all questions
which are quite random uh
like what is Jason's favorite animal do
you know any of the answers
um
Platypus no no dolphin
what was Jason's favorite subject at
school this is very hard politics no ah
no economics no oh my God no geography
it's really random really cool thing oh
no
given the nature of this game how about
this for a question does Jason believe
in nuclear disarmament
yes it does yeah what is Jason's
favorite day of the week
Saturday no no
I had I did take a lot of drugs in the
night
it was Sunday what is Jason's favorite
building in New York
um the pier
you're not very good at this anyway lots
of Australia to make it big in Hollywood
have come through the Australian so yeah
the Soaps like home in a way neighbors
not me
if you audition for them or anything I
didn't even get a chance to audition my
very first agent meeting I got rejected
because they like looked at me up and
down and said yeah you're not ever going
to be on home and away so we're not
going to take you
um is that the only job in Australia
but now you tweeted this picture
recently of yourself when you were
starting out is this like a head shot
you would do for audition my first
acting headshot
um there are a lot of questions
okay why am I holding a softball mitt
and a softball just in case you didn't
get that out of sporty yeah
can play athletes yeah yeah I guess yeah
and then I'm wearing like the world's
finest gold chain
uh and then because you're feminine as
well yeah
a size t-shirt I've just let my hair go
feral you know
obviously had not met up with a
professional stylist at that point in my
career
can I just like like the random graffiti
because I didn't come from like kind of
the ghetto area of Sydney
just have like a plain background yeah
she's a rebel like yeah but no wonder
nobody thought I would be a professional
actress
that headshot like you can't you can't
stage something no you look like you
were in a great mood and then you saw
something truly awful
yeah there you go that's it that's it
yeah and you've been in the business for
such a long long time that you're
looking back are you wow
as a child
when I was 16 I did a TV show in
Australia yeah it was 10 years ago five
years ago I'm 32 now I'm 16. wow okay
you look very beautiful oh thanks
they're about to hit you
[Applause]
okay assistant the singles no L'Oreal
she loves L'oreal L'oreal commercial she
could paint oh is it paint no it's the
you know
apparently I'm not worth it anymore
when you had to do the because I'm worse
yes I was fantastic it's so much fun
it's so ridiculous dude as an actress do
you try to mean it you know because I'm
worth it or do you just say oh it's
money and say it
um
you get into character you get it
[Music]
because I'm worth it
to say in different languages too see
really oh can you do it in other
languages I can't remember them
who can speak French what's that how do
you say it in French
oh
yeah
because I'm a cow
[Applause]
okay before we actually get on to why
you're here I've got to ask you about
when you were a student when you're a
drama student you had this this is a
bizarre story we had a house that was
quite inexpensive to rent in Sydney is
this true
yes like most acting students but wasn't
it bizarrely cheap to rent oh no no I I
stayed in a in a house in a suburb
called zetland which is right underneath
a smokestack and I think everyone had
asthma and I think the smoke snacks
longer there but um no there was someone
was murdered in my room but I discovered
in a really awful it was horrible when
you were there yeah no someone handed me
a DVD of a straight there's a show
called Australia's most Wanted dude
Britain's Most Wanted crime watch yes
and
um Britain's Got Talent
foreign
which I was staying which was at the
time was only 60 a week which is
incredibly cheap I was watching it in in
my bed and I watched a man climb in
through my window and strangle a woman
in my bed oh and there was a woman
murdered and so for years I would
thought well this is my chance to sort
of meet a ghost there's been you know
such a traumatic thing going on here and
then um it didn't I didn't encounter
anything until the day that I left the
house was finally disbanding and I shut
the door and I heard Kate
and I was I did send there's no one in
there there was no one in there well I
was there no yeah but there's nothing I
wasn't taking to myself
no no it was a it was really oga booga